all right to our chronovirus coverage
here at six o'clock nearly 2.3 million
people have now been tested for coven 19
all across our state since the pandemic
started but
officials say even more testing is
needed to get a handle on the spread of
this deadly virus
hector mejia is live from one of the
testing sites here in town with the
changes you'll see
starting today good morning hector
hey there good morning and this is texas
station right behind us where
at least about a dozen cars are lining
up right now to get a test two hours
before they even open
this place has been serving as a mass
testing facility for months and starting
today
they'll have new hours let's go over
those new hours the drive-through
testing here at texas station will
operate
only wednesdays thursdays and fridays
starting at 8 a.m
it's no longer open on weekends clark
county the national guard
and the health district will continue to
run the operations
and all the testing is done on a first
come first served basis that's why we
see long lines starting early this
morning
it's free and insurance is not needed
here there are still two other major
testing sites which are overseen by umc
those are at unlv and cashman center
starting this week though those sites
began asking for insurance information
there's no out-of-pocket cost even if
you don't have insurance but the
insurance of those who have it will be
billed
to recoup some of the costs and
appointments at those places speaking of
unlv and cashman center
appointments there are highly highly
encouraged reporting live this morning
hector mejia
8 news now